the former top cyber security official
responsible for securing the
presidential election
who was fired by president trump is
speaking to 60 minutes
earlier this month christopher krebs
called the election the
most secure in american history 60
minutes correspondent scott pelley sat
down with the former director of the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency
he was says it was his first interview
since he was forced
out last week
was the most secure in american history
there is no evidence
that any voting system deleted or lost
votes or changed votes or was in
any way compromised yeah i stand by that
the president tweeted after that
statement quote the recent statement by
kris krebs
on the security of the 2020 election was
highly
inaccurate in that there were massive
improprieties and fraud do you remember
what the president said at the end of
that tweet
oh i was terminated that yes
i i recall that were you surprised
i don't know if i was necessarily
surprised
it's not how i wanted to go out
i think i uh
the thing that upsets me the most about
that is i didn't get a
chance uh to say goodbye to my team
and i'd worked with them for three and a
half years
in the trenches building an agency
putting sissa
on the national stage and
uh i love that team and i didn't get a
chance to say goodbye so
that's what i'm most upset about you can
see
more of scott pelley's interview with
christopher krebs this sunday
on 60 minutes